hi I'm Eric Boston this is a breakdown
of the dark night directed by Chris
Nolan written by Nolan and gentlemen
without from Dave Goya after covering
Batman Begins we now have arrived at the
Dark Knight which came out exactly ten
years ago today it's an awesome film
that inspired me to be a filmmaker and a
YouTube psycho devours Easter eggs
because with the Dark Knight Kristen
will improve that comic book movies can
be made with attention to detail win
lots of awards and make it cool to be a
nerd and have no girlfriend and measure
your worth and read it up those but
unlike the other many internet love
letters to this movie here we're gonna
re-watch this movie scene my scene and
point out all the cool details that make
the Dark Knight great that you might
have missed the first 10 times you
watched it little Easter eggs but also
cinematic devices subtle influences all
the deeper truths that you really want
out of an obsessive commentary let's get
started before the movie even begins our
first image shows a wall of flames
engulfing the Batman logo now Nolan has
open all three of his Batman movies with
some kind of Elemental image reader
foreshadow the way Batman gets tested in
each installment in this case the flames
tease Batman's upcoming trial by fire
The Joker later mentions gasoline as one
of his favorite weapons because fire is
cheap but effective and we will see the
Joker use fire throughout this movie and
devastating ways bombing the judges car
blowing up the hospital setting a giant
pile of money ablaze and of course
killing Rachel Dawes and burning Harvey
Dent to create two-face it's all part of
the plan to break that man and onto the
opening bank robbery whoo baby now six
months before this movie even came out a
group of friends and I drove two hours
to the nearest IMAX theater to see a
special advanced screening of these
first six minutes and every time I watch
a sequence I discover something new that
I love about it so indulge baby first we
open on a shot of Gotham skyline now as
we'll see throughout this movie the city
of Gotham is actually its own principal
character in this movie it's people
served as a microcosm for all of
humanity and the conflict of this movie
ultimately boils down to a battle for
Gotham's soul Nolan stresses this idea
by shooting the city which is set in
Chicago from all angles
lots of aerial shots showing the
vertical skyline but also the street
level in the shadow of the l-train
and down below on lower Wacker Drive you
get a real sense of Gotham as a living
breathing city with its own
multi-dimensional personality right away
we also get a tease of the
music hans zimmer compose for this movie
this is the Joker's theme and it's very
simple starting with a single D note
played on electric cello that's the same
instrument Zimmer would later use for
Wonder Woman's themed Zimmer also
experimented with razor blades on piano
wire in shards of metal on guitar
strings all to give the Joker's theme a
more jagged texture to it Chris Nolan
insisted on all the music in his Batman
movies to be originally scored
forbidding the use of any rocker pop
songs even in the trailers Jonah Nolan
said that he wanted to use the Rolling
Stones paint it black for a trailer but
it never happened don't worry gonna we
got you covered
after a quick reflection the helicopter
in the window just to show us that no
one's perfect the Joker's elaborate
heist begins we down on the street we
push in on the Joker in his clown mask
now all of these clown masks were
designed uniquely for each character the
costume designer Lindy hemming said that
the Joker and his gang would have gotten
hold of a box of plain white masks and
that each would have painted his own
clown makeup on it actually the Joker's
mask is a specific nod to Batman history
this is the same design worn by Cesar
Romero's Joker in an episode of the 60s
Batman TV series when he hijacked a
performance of Pagliacci The Joker masks
himself hiding in plain sight remaining
silent as his goons gossip about him as
I mentioned in the last video all three
of these movies open with the villain
hiding in plain sight letting his
reputation precedes him before he
reveals himself and notice things
strange here three of a kind let's do
this I see three guys two guys on the
roof every guy gets a share five shares
is plenty six years
don't forget the guy playing the job he
thinks he can sit it out and still take
a slice I know what they call them the
Joker okay a few things here first the
guy says three of a kind which of course
is a hand in poker the Joker's emblem is
a joker playing card and references to
poker and gambling come up throughout
the movie I'll show ya when the chips
are down you need
an ace-in-the-hole we bet it on this
gambling motif reflects the significance
of game theory in the Dark Knight game
theory is a study of mathematical models
of the way people interact and seek the
optimal outcome for themselves it's used
in economics and political science and
yeah poker if you know what you're doing
the jokerz scheme here is a gamble he
hired five other thieves to help steal a
massive loot but he secretly told some
of them to kill another thief resulting
in a larger share ultimately leaving him
to take the whole pot for himself this
plot is inspired by a game theory
thought experiment called the pirate
game where a group of pirates negotiate
to split up a treasure deciding whom to
kill to take a larger share the solution
for the senior-most pirate is to bribe
the weakest pirate to conspire against
the other pirates the joker plays these
clowns the same way bribing them against
each other in order to serve himself the
manager of this Bank is no pushover he's
of course in the pocket of organized
crime so he fights back with a shotgun
notice how he fires at the robbers
without caring at all about the
innocence in the line of fire in the
background some of them had to have been
hit this actor is william fichtner who
has been on everything he's in
Armageddon in Black Hawk Down and
Michael Mann's heat which was the
primary cinematic influence on the Dark
Knight Nolan looked to heat as a road
map to make a Batman movie as a
thoughtful thrill Ian's cops and robbers
tale both movies begin with elaborate
heists though this bank robbery is
probably closer to the big bank robbery
later in heat where duffle bags stuffed
with cash same way - lights studies have
actually been done showing that these
bags would weigh over 350 pounds finally
the Joker reveals himself
Stranger vikner looks genuinely shaken
here and he's reflecting our shock the
first time we saw his Ledger's face in
this movie from the beginning of this
process Nolan and ledger conceived of a
Joker that was completely different from
Jack Nicholson's portrayal in Tim
Burton's Batman which at the time this
movie started production was probably
one of the most iconic movie characters
of all time they actually looked - punk
rockers like Sid Vicious and Johnny
Rotten and the clothing styles of people
like Iggy Pop and Adam Ant they also
looked at Alex from A Clockwork Orange
both the Malcolm McDowell movie version
and the version of the book as a
psychopathic gang leader who delights in
his sadism
Nolan also cited the paintings of
Francis Bacon which inspired this
Joker's bleak distorted sweaty face
ledger reportedly stayed alone in a
motel for six weeks perfecting his
characters mannerisms movement and voice
he actually invoked ventriloquist
dummies to create this Joker's
disconnected mocking quality some have
also compared his voice to the singer
Tom Waits I have a growing level of
popularity and of course the most
striking thing about him visually is his
face historically the Joker's appearance
was a result of his skin getting
bleached after falling in an open vat of
ACE chemicals but this Joker wears
makeup Ledger would apply this makeup
himself that's why whenever you see a
close-up of Ledger's hands in the movie
you can see dry paint smeared on his
fingers and under his fingernails and of
course his smile is a result of scars
this is actually called a Glasgow smile
popular among street gangs in the UK in
the 20s and 30s and made even more
famous in the black dahlia case in Los
Angeles in 1947 for the movie these
scars were made with three pieces of
stamped silicon which ledger had to keep
crowding with his tongue to keep it for
peeling off he actually transform this
into a facial tic of the character with
the Joker constantly licking his scars
like a dog almost these facial scars
were also on the main character from
Victor Hugo's novel the man who laughs
in the 1928 movie that title was
actually used for a joker graphic novel
the man who laughs which is actually one
of the big comic influences for the Dark
Knight notice how the Joker shoots the
bus driver without looking at him he
actually kills a lot of people
throughout this movie without making eye
contact with him and that could be
inspired from a lime in the man who
laughs he didn't even look at them like
killing them wasn't
importance and speaking of source
material from the DC Comics some have
observed a little DC shoutout and
Zimmer's music here notice how the
second that the Joker reveals himself
the music goes from a D down to AC
simply make sure or if you're a
tone-deaf sceptic be as Nolan described
Ledger as fearless which is actually key
to the Joker as I discussed in Batman
Begins each of the main characters in
that movie were defined by their
relationship with fear but the Joker is
the first character in this trilogy
truly without fear so he is nothing to
lose this makes the Dark Knight all
about dualities and the Joker and Batman
are two sides of the same coin
Batman represents order and the Joker
represents Anarchy but I'll get to more
of that later one last detail before I
move on check out the school buses
license plate the crew custom made these
Gotham license plates but they model
them to look like Illinois license
plates since they shot the movie in
Chicago and Illinois plates would have
been showing up in the background so we
move on to Jim Gordon with Gary Oldman
returning in the role waiting by the
bat-signal he's greeted by his rookie
Ramirez such you had to go look after
your mother detectives checked her back
into the hospital now we know later that
Harvey Dent doesn't trust cops like
Ramirez but right away she gives us a
smoking gun in the form of this shady
little ice shift later it's revealed
that it was Ramirez who betrayed Harvey
Dent because she was in debt to the
Joker's gang for her mother's medical
bills then we move on to this drug deal
with dr. crane aka scarecrow with
Killian Murphy reprising his character
from Batman Begins for just a cameo in
this movie this deal is interrupted by
these copycat bat men they're one of the
vigilantes who dress up like Batman and
they're based on these sons of Batman
and Frank Miller's The Dark Knight
Returns which is another major comic
influence on Nolan's movies after
busting up the deal Batman scolds the
copycats I'm not
whoo turn down the bass honestly when I
first heard this line I was like what
are hockey pants yeah Christian Bale has
gotten some heat for his Batman voice
actually while shooting this movie he
actually used the voice that was similar
to the one he used a Batman Begins but
Nolan felt Batman in a grittier rasp so
he had bail actually rerecord his lines
in post-production so take it up with
Nolan after this when Batman meets with
Gordon and the bank vaults notice the
security camera photo of the Joker it's
dated a 2008 718 this was the movies
released bade July 18th 2008 Alfred
Pennyworth Michael Caine stitches up
Bruce in the temporary Batcave after
Bruce's mansion burned down in Batman
Begins and we move on to Rachel Dawes in
court with Maggie Gyllenhaal now playing
the role after Katie Holmes opted not to
return joining her is Harvey Dent
Aaron Eckhart the newly elected District
Attorney you may remember the Dark
Knight had a super elaborate viral
marketing campaign of the year before
the release with a big part of it
centered around this fictional election
with a fake website showing the slogan I
believe in Harvey Dent Eckhardt bases
performance of dent on Bobby Kennedy a
similarly dashing and idealistic
attorney slash politician whose career
became sort of driven by revenge who of
course had a very dark end that saw him
becoming a murderer he's prosecuting Sal
Maroni who has taken over the Falcone
crime organization since Falcone of
Boston and that man begins and one of
maroney's guys pulls a gun on dent but
it misfires and for a second this
recalled a moment in the Batman comic
the long Halloween which is another big
influence on Nolan's movies in the long
Halloween Harvey Dent was attacked
during trial when Sal Maroni throws acid
on his face disfiguring him and driving
him insane
we actually saw this version of events
and news footage and Batman Forever
afterward dent meets with Gordon in his
office and the two men are hesitant to
trust each other you don't have to sell
me Dad no no
got some sweet late yeah well I heard
they have a different name for me down
at MC you know with the term the white
night Gordon provides the first
reference to this movie's title the Dark
Knight and that other name dent refers
to we later learn is Harvey two-face
this is another example of that duality
concept I brought up earlier attempts
character token is his double-headed
coin he uses it to manipulate people a
literal representation of his two-faced
reputation but like the Joker dentists
also on one side of the same coin as the
hero Batman and Joker reflect the
duality between order and chaos while
Harvey Dent and Bruce Wayne reflect the
duality of the White Knight and the Dark
Knight's more on this in a bit Bruce
meets with Lucius Fox Morgan Freeman now
run in Wayne Enterprises and he asks for
a new suit want to be able to turn your
head shortly a backing out of the
driveway yeah this is kind of a meta
joke about the past movie versions of
the Batman suit and witch's cowl was
connected and one piece to his neck and
shoulders so that if you wanted to turn
his head he had to like turn his whole
body next we move on to the restaurants
now take a look at this dude sitting at
the table next to them INRI watches a
number of viewers have speculated that
this kind of looks like Heath Ledger
without makeup and that the Joker could
be spying on Harvey and Rachel I have
you look closely this definitely isn't
ledger this guy doesn't have scars but
all admit it does look a lot like the
actor especially from behind it could
actually be the actor stand-in filling
in as an extra here Bruce in his date
Natasha that prima ballerina join them
in a double date and Harvey defends
Batman by comparing Gotham to ancient
Rome this actually continues Ra's al
Ghul's historical comparison for Batman
Begins though Roz's comparison was more
cynical referring to Gotham's corruption
and coming collapse like Rome
whereas Harvey's comparison is
idealistic he's referring to Rome's
Republic form of government and then
Harvey states a key theme you either die
a hero or you live long enough to see
yourself become the villain
Harvey is referring to Julius Caesar for
whom absolute power corrupted absolutely
and later applies to Harvey himself whom
Gordon a Batman decide to allow to die a
hero rather than the truth of his
villainous epilogue become public but
within this statement lies a deeper
meaning about the nature of heroism
Harvey is suggesting that a true hero
sacrifices signalling to Bruce said he
could be more than just a white knight
you know
a hero who leads and inspires he could
also be a true hero one who gives up
what he loves this parallelism between
Harvey and Bruce is reflected in Natasha
covering the top half of Harvey's face
with a white menu creating the image of
a white night doppelganger of Batman but
of course this image also foreshadows a
very different paid for Harvey's face or
you know well half of it next we move on
to the Joker's meeting with the crime
bosses in the kitchen including the
chechen Maroni and gamble and of course
the Joker shows off his infamous pencil
trick but just so we're clear The Joker
totally put that pencil through the
dudes eye socket it's a real documented
medical injury called transorbital
intracranial penetrating injury where
people have jammed all kinds of things
into their heads through their eyes and
pluton pencils so don't try it kids the
Joker makes a deal with the bosses kill
the Batman so they can return to their
regular criminal business as usual in
exchange for half of their fortune half
The Joker's reaction here is interesting
he seems genuinely miffed at being
called crazy now that could be because
he's actually thought this out all the
way through he's once again employing
game theory in this case it's called the
shrinking pie game two kids have an ice
cream pie that's quickly melting and the
longer they wait to figure out how to
divide that pie the less overall pie
they had to eat basically the ideas
waiting is costly in this case the
bosses profits are the shrinking pie and
according to the rules of this game when
you look into it
The Joker's initial offer of 50% is
extremely reasonable so yeah he's right
he's definitely not crazy
since Lau moved the boss's money
Gordon's raid was a bust
leading Gordon Dent and Batman arguing
on the rooftop here we see the three
heroes fighting to save Gotham in their
own ways all failing because they refuse
to fully trust each other no one conveys
this distrust and bewilderment with an
interesting camera movement four means
started to see notice how he orbits the
camera around them letting the actors
bark at each other in real-time
it's almost like the three of them are
caught in a tornado tornados eyes or
just a tornado of bureaucratic and
jurisdictional confusion leading them to
spin out of control the city the
whirlwind only stops when they agree on
a solution use Batman to extradite Lao
Fox recommends the Brousseau a way to
get back into a plane without it landing
a CIA program called skyhook skyhook is
actually a real thing from CIA history
its official name was the Fulton
surface-to-air recovery system and it
works as we see it in the movie with a
balloon that inflates and connects to a
harness that reels someone onto a plane
in midair was actually featured in
double-oh-seven movie Thunderball
remember this is another example of
Nolan using real-world military
technology to justify the plausibility
of Batman's gadgets as he did all over
the place in Batman Begins nothing in
these movies comes off as to comic book
II this Batman could exist in our world
and he does Fox also goes Bruce's new
armor allowing flexibility and agility
but gaps in the plates expose them to
knives and other threats
how will a hold up against dogs we're
talking Rottweilers what's your Wallis
should do fine against cats now for many
viewers fox's joke about cat seemed to
be a teaser for Catwoman to appear the
third movie and Batman Returns Michelle
Pfeiffer's Catwoman does stick a claw in
the gap and
Batman's armor in these fans we're kind
of right Catwoman does appear in the
Dark Knight Rises but it ends up being
another woman who stabs a knife through
the gap in Batman's armor Talia al Ghul
meanwhile the Joker poses as a dead body
to get a jump on gamble it's a little
hard to tell here but if you look
closely you can see that Joker stabbed
two of gambles men and used their bodies
as leverage to lift himself up very cool
The Joker tells gamble a story about how
he got his scars abuse from an alcoholic
father he turns to me and he says why so
serious he comes at me with the knife
why so serious now of course we learned
this is just one explanation for Joker
scars we learned later that he's
actually an unreliable narrator but by
painting the Joker as a victim of abuse
in this moment Nolan almost tricks us
into feeling sympathy for the character
and seeing a possible vulnerability in
his complex psychology daddy issues how
wrong we were and listen to the music
here why so serious that Joker theme of
a steady denote bends upward to a D
sharp kind of like a plane crashing oh
really it's d and d sharp being played
together at the same time blended unlike
notes that are separated by several
steps and can produce harmony when
played together two notes separated by
only a half step played together is just
really jarring it feels like a mistake
and that uncomfortable tension from the
music contributes to the overall unease
we feel in this moment the Joker is
apparent emotional breakdown with his
blade and Gamble's cheat Joker makes the
three remaining members of gambles gang
fight with a snapped pool stick for a
spot in his crew and this is one of many
examples of the Joker manipulating his
enemies against each other but it also
foreshadows his ultimate plan in a third
act these three men paralleled the three
men trying to save Gotham in both cases
the Joker aims to turn one of the three
against the other two so just like the
snapped pool stick he snaps dense sanity
and turns him against those other two
moving on to Hong Kong and Batman's
capture of Lau this is all fun but one
detail I want to point out about this
sequence before Batman swoops in allows
building notice the time bombs Batman
sticks in the windows we see one
counting down from 2 minutes and 23
seconds these bombs explode almost
exactly this amount of time later
in real time Nolan edited the sequence
so that Batman captures Lao within the
countdown two minutes earlier and our
experience watching it no one may not
play around with timelines and his
Batman movies as much as he does and his
other works momento inception
interstellar Dunkirk but it definitely
shows an attention to detail when it
comes to time and countdowns
when Lao gets interrogated Harvey and
Rachel realize that they can charge all
the gangs using Rico that's a real life
federal law passed in the 70s that has
been used to prosecute criminal
organizations looting the Hells Angels
Mafia families street gangs up and
crooked government agencies dent meets
with Mayor Anthony Garcia played by
Nestor Carbonell
aka Richard from lost his caution speech
a dent leads to the biggest jump scare
of the movie swiftly by you and me yeah
okay this is the copycat that we saw in
the earlier scene and the Joker is
fastened a devilish Joker card with the
words will the real Batman please stand
up which of course is a reference to
Eminem's the real Slim Shady
Joker's handheld video of this copycats
death is harrowing it was actually
recorded by Heath Ledger himself under
Nolan's supervision but after it turned
out so well Nolan allowed Ledger to
record the later handheld video with
Mike angle all on his own during this
video the Joker roars at the copycats
the Joker is obsessed with this kind of
attention as we saw when the Joker
answered that bank manager's question by
simply revealing his scars the Joker
knows that the mere sight of his Glasgow
smile and deranged makeup produces the
exact fear and disorder in others that
he so desperately craves moving on to
Bruce's fundraiser party for Harvey
which begins with this key exchange
between Harvey and Alfred Alfred ready
that's right sir Rachel talks about you
all the time you've known her her whole
life oh not yet I'm just foreshadowing
her death later in the movies and
speaking of foreshadowing Bruce also
throws lists at us look at this face
this is the face of Gotham's bright
future a face perfectly proportional
between its rightness left a face spree
from blemishes or scars or burns and I
will never have to face these words
coming back to haunt me also notice
Bruce's dates if you haven't already
been ugly there are three of them now a
step up from the two he brought with him
and bat
begins and some said that with Bruce the
colors of all their outfits could be
reflecting the cyan magenta yellow and
black of the CMYK printers that comic
books are printed in the you're
stretching it music sting is coming back
the as the Joker up ends the night by
hitting his three targets simultaneously
Police Commissioner Loeb by poisoning
his liquor with dry ice I guess judge
Cirillo by blowing up her car and of
course crashing dents party and check
out Alfred the moment the Joker bursts
in from the elevator this scene was shot
early in production and Michael Caine
said that this was the first time he met
Leger face-to-face and he was so shocked
to see Ledger's face that he forgot his
lines and noticed the Joker's actions
here where our ears Harvey Dent
this is another example of the duality
between Bruce and the Joker moments
earlier remember Bruce entered the party
the same exact way arriving fashionably
late asking where is Harvey and tossing
out his champagne both men presumably
throw out their drinks to stay sober and
sharp to avoid getting sloppy but to
keep up the illusion that they're just
having fun then notice this old party
guest that the Joker interacts with
we're not intimidated by thugs you
remind me of my father
this guy is US Senator Patrick Leahy
from Vermont he is a huge Batman fan he
also makes a cameo in the Dark Knight
Rises along with cameos in Batman
Forever and Batman in the animated
series this moment also reminds us of
the Joker's story about his scars which
remember he previously said he received
from an abusive father being reminded of
that sympathy we felt that the character
of results in a bigger shock when the
Joker gives Rachel a new explanation so
I had a wife who gambles and gets in
deep
the Sharks one day they carve her face I
just want to see her smile again
so I stick a razor in my mouth and do
this this is the moment we feel the most
frightened at the Joker because we've
realized that his story about his dad
was complete we now realized that we
can't trust a word out of this guy's
mouth he's a true psychopath the idea to
not to give the Joker a definitive
backstory was decided by the Nolan's
early in their writing process they took
inspiration from The Killing Joke by
Alan Moore in which the Joker narrates
the tragic backstory but he later says
if I had a past it would be multiple
choice many readers concluded that this
made the Joker an unreliable narrator
and that we could never truly know what
his origin was also notice on Nolan once
again spins the camera around the Joker
and raychel accentuating that's
disorienting revelation it's as if that
dizzy whirlwind of Lies that dent Gordon
a Batman were in earlier was caused by
this unpredictable tornado that Batman
operates in the Joker's peripheral
vision miraculously saving Rachel lady
and Bruce and Alfred to try to
understand the Joker's MO complicated
Alfred this line is a callback to Batman
Begins remember Ra's al Ghul said these
same words to Bruce a criminal is not
complicated the fact that Bruce still
Peretz Ra's al Ghul's absolute isms show
that he still has a lot more to learn
about the complexity of the criminal
mind
Alfred responds with his awesome
anecdote for a time he was a soldier
hunting a bandit in Burma who kept
stealing jewels and just throwing them
away because some men are looking for
anything logical like money they can't
be bought bullied reasoned wanna go
I did with some men just want to watch
the world burn with this line alfrid
links the Joker's nihilism with the fire
imagery that we saw in the opening
frames it's also just a really cool eye
Batman's search for the Joker leads him
to overhear 9-1-1 call but it's not
Harvey Dent of course it's two random
men with Harvey and dent in their last
names it's a gruesome crime scene and
the Joker leaves the clue behind in the
form of his fingerprint on the bullet
that Batman recovers from the wall this
whole serial killers style by the Joker
seems to parallel John Doe the killer
from the movie se7en both killers remain
anonymous but they leave fingerprints
behind a lead the cops chasing them into
a trap they both get arrested on purpose
to enact a secret darker plan that
actually involves killing the heroes
love interest and then they actually go
to the hero into killing him to prove
correct his nihilistic worldview in both
movies that Morgan Freeman proved and
speaking to Freeman during this Lucius
Fox meets with Coleman Reese an
accountant at Wayne Enterprises who
uncovers the truth that Fox's supply in
Batman's weaponry now Reese's name is
kind of an easter egg mr. Reese sounds
like mysteries which is similar to
Edward nygma enigma the Riddler who is
also an employee at Wayne's company in
the hush comics and in Batman Forever
nygma also deduces Batman's identity
some speculated that this could be
setting up the Riddler as the villain
for the third Nolan Batman movie but
they ended up going with a bigger guy
for you moving on to Commissioner lobes
funeral where the Joker has threatened
to kill the mayor we get a quick look at
the man underneath the makeup during
this assassination attempt The Joker and
his gang replaced the honor guard in the
funeral gun salute and he takes a shot
at the mayor now it's amazing how he
just blends in hiding in plain sight
like a full minute earlier you can see
him in a wide shot front and center
directly in the eye lines of Rachel and
Harvey and Gordon that's not until the
trigger-happy snipers fire at Bruce's
window by mistake that Gordon just looks
down finally to see the guard with
terrifying distinct facial scars and it
dives them to protect the mayor now
having the Dro corps dressed up as a cop
is a detail from the Joker's very first
appearance in Batman issue number one
that issue also features him smuggling a
bomb into a prison to escape stealing
from the mob and his crimes being driven
not by personal gain but for general
disorder all of which the Joker
does in this movie in the aftermath of
the shooting Harvey kidnaps a Joker
associate using his double sided coin to
try to force a confession out of the
paranoid schizophrenic Batman stops him
saying Harvey needs to remain a white
knight but seeing Harvey gets so
aggressive and cruel here shows that
there's already an inner darkness to him
so it's easy to blame his turn in the
two-face on the burn scars and losing
Rachel but before this even happens
Harvey Dent is a guy who uses fear
maliciously similar to Nolan's villains
and Batman Begins he's really a step
away from flipping to this dark side as
Bruce prepares to turn himself in Alfred
advises him to in do the public scorn of
the Joker killing people every day that
he stays in the shadows
Alfred provides another hint at the
answer of the thematic question posed
earlier what makes the true hero
well someone willing to be hated Dent
holds a press conference with my
favorite heckler in a superhero movie
Harvey tries to calm Gotham the night is
darkest just before the dawn
this is also just some good wordplay
foreshadowing the movie's dramatic
climax this white knight will descend to
his darkest state right before the dawn
implied by the beams of light that
Batman rides off into in the final frame
the fact that Harvey takes Batman's
place here turning himself in just
another example of this whole white
knight Dark Knight duality Harvey
becomes Batman at least in the public's
eye and his sacrifice prevents Batman
from taking on that weight of society
himself that this movie is saying true
heroism requires so for Batman to grow
into the hero he's destined to be dent
has to go the two heads of the same coin
cannot both show their faces at the same
time that brings us to this movie's
thrilling chase sequence where the Joker
attacks Harvey in the police convoy as
it's being transported through the city
the semi truck that the Joker chases
them down in says laughter is the best
medicine with an S spray painted on it
to make it slaughter the Joker fires on
the SWAT truck with the increasing
firepower first an automatic handgun
then a shotgun and a freaking RPG within
less than a minute - the Joker
exemplifies the exact kind of escalation
that Gordon warn Batman about in the
final scene of Batman Begins we start
carrying my own
today by autumn I the crash Batmobile
gives birth to the Batpod which Batman
uses to flip the Joker's trick Leedy
into this game chicken between them
the Joker isn't lying here he doesn't
want to kill Batman he doesn't fire at
the Batpod he just fires at other cars
to clear paths for Batman to himself he
genuinely wants Batman to kill him but
it doesn't happen to use the Joker's
analogy the two of them are an
unstoppable force in an unmovable object
Nolan's camerawork flames the
unstoppable Batman to the unmovable
Joker but at the last second the forces
repel each other kind of like a police
charged and sub magnets now we get to
the core of this relationship in just a
bit The Joker ends up being caught by
Gordon still alive disguised as the SWAT
driver the batman comic the long hat
lean also features Batman posing as a
SWAT officer and dent faking his death
both of which were reassigned to Gordon
in this movie harvey is exonerated and
freed briefly but we see that he's not
headed to safety the cops puttin him in
the car our Joker influenced detectives
shifty eyes Ramirez and Wirtz is the
worst
well the Joker sits in the prison cell
notice its reaction to the large
mentally disturbed man who gets thrown
in with him you can see the Joker
silently registering that his plan is in
place his gang surgically implanted a
cell phone bomb in this man's torso so
now the Joker knows he's ready to talk
and send the police out to rescue Rachel
and Harvey moving on to the Dark
Knight's iconic interrogation scene
between Batman and the Joker now I
mentioned before that Nolan followed the
story beats of Michael Mann's heat and
this scene is the parallel of that
movie's midpoint diner scene between
Pacino and De Niro wins super cop and
super criminal realized they actually
share a similar humanity The Joker also
points out a commonality between these
two characters today I'm here just a
freak like me
the Joker goes further to underline
their codependence I'm gonna kill you
what would I do without you go back to
ripping out my dealers no no no no you
you
me unlike the duality between Batman and
Harvey Dent where they cannot coexist
this duality between Batman and the
Joker requires that they coexist each
extreme is defined at least partly by
the nature of the opposite extreme also
yeah the Joker's dude an impression of
Tom Cruise's romantic speech and Jerry
Maguire you compete which could be a
ledger trolling cruise who according to
rumors pressured Katie Holmes who was
his wife at the time against returning
as Rachel Dawes that hot Goss is too hot
for hot sauce Nolan does an interesting
trick with the camera in the scene now
normally in conversation scenes in
movies one character stays on the left
side of the frame looking rightward and
the other stays on the right side of
frame looking leftward by following this
rule the viewer doesn't get disoriented
when the frame cuts it back forth
between the angles but Nolan slides the
camera he changes the eyeline he starts
a conversation with Batman on the left
looking right joker begins on the right
looking leftward but as the Joker talks
the camera slides to the left
repositioning Batman from the left side
to the right side of the frame and the
Joker now on the left then Nolan does it
again when the Joker says you're just a
freak
he slides back right shifting Batman
back to the left side of the frame in
the Joker back to the right this
Sorrentine camera movement reflects the
Joker did him in Batman's head he's
leaving him questioning his morals
Nolan violates the eye line rule to
parallel the Joker goading Batman into
violating his only rule the only
sensible way to live in this world is
without rules to break the Joker is
showing his hand here he doesn't want to
kill Batman he wants to turn him to flip
the Dark Knight from noble vigilante to
Wallis executioner and break Gotham's
moral backbone and drag it into the
chaotic Anarchy he desires knowing
Harvey and Rachel or threatened turns
Batman super violent apparently Heath
Ledger told Christian Bale to actually
punch him in the face and Nolan had to
cut Batman kicking Joker on his way out
of the room because it felt too brutal
The Joker forces Batman to make a choice
so why does Batman choose Rachel here
for love no well yeah kinda Bruce
chooses Rachel over Harvey because he's
still selfish he doesn't yet understand
that a true hero makes a personal
sacrifice for the greater good of
society and we'll see how this mistake
changes him
while Batman and Gordon brush off the
Joker escapes by goading detective
Stevens into assaulting him The Joker
gets out by using one of these shattered
shards of mirror glass from when Batman
smashed his head against here it's just
a little detail reminding us how
Batman's selfish anger creates happiness
exposing a vulnerability Rachele of
course dies and the explosion and half
of Harvey's face gets horribly burned
The Joker uses his phone call to
detonate the gut bomb and escape with
Lao in short we are at rock bottom or as
it's called as a term in screenwriting
the dark night of the soul I think the
fact that this movie's title shares a
homophonic name with a classic beat and
storytelling in movies signals to us
that this moment is when we really need
to be watching the character because
this is when it becomes the hero that we
know Bruce sits defeated yeah the way
Alfred tries to comfort him actually is
beat for beat the same conversation as
the one when Bruce was a boy after his
parents funeral in Batman Begins Alfred
offers food Bruce isn't hungry very well
then Alfred way yes master Bruce all the
while the same sad hans zimmer music
plays this scene ends with Bruce asking
Alfred how he stopped that bandit in
Burma from his anecdote earlier we bone
to flourish down so here we go for Bruce
this sets up the Gless in he has to
learn for this movie's final act for one
he needs to burn the forests of Gotham
down forcing the Joker out in the open
by expanding Fox's sonar surveillance
but on a thematic level he needs to be
willing to sacrifice everything that's
what a hero is
meanwhile Harvey Dent's lucky to set a
coin now as one side of it burned
conveying to him that Rachel didn't
survive the fire this is also some
elegant visual storytelling with this
character token now Marda the same way
he is both on the surface of his skin
and deep down in the soul the two faces
of Harvey two-face are now
distinguishable from each other making
him a surface value honest man he's just
now driven to the extreme of honesty
obsessed with fairness to attain juris
degree that duality that he once shared
as the white knight that Bruce's Dark
Knight is gone he now just exists as a
duality unto himself a dr. Jekyll and
mr. Hyde figure the following visit from
Gordon reveals Harvey's new face and
this is one of the few instances of
nolan using cgi to generate a
character's features nearly did so
because he felt that any added make-up
would make
Hertz face bigger and he wanted to
subtract and make it look like the fire
had burned a tissue away while the Joker
burns the massive pile of the mobs money
with Lao on top of it he calls in to
Gotham tonight to place a hit on Coleman
Reese before Reese can expose Batman's
identity now this is a major change from
the Joker's previously announced goal to
out Batman he does it now because as
mentioned before he needs Batman so that
he could break Batman to deliver his
message to the people of Gotham that
anyone can be corrupted even Batman and
the Joker places his hit by once again
forcing an undesirable ultimatum kill
race or I blow up a hospital
Bruce protects Reese by driving in front
of a ramming truck with his sports car
this is actually a Lamborghini
Murcielago sorry for the
mispronunciation in the word murciélago
is Spanish for bat so essentially this
is Bruce's daytime Pat 'mobile the
hospital evac slated it's great scene
with the Joker confronting Harvey Hall
dressed as a nurse and if you look
closely this uniform you can see and I
believe in Harvey Dent campaign sticker
now there is a lot going on in this
scene first the Joker describes himself
in an interesting way do I really look
like a guy with a plan you know what I
am I'm a dog chasing cars I wouldn't
know what to do with one if I caught it
so this kind of canine imagery when it
comes to the Joker is another motif that
runs throughout the Dark Knight we see
it in the way he licks his mouth how he
sticks his head out of the police car
window after escaping how he feeds the
Chechen to his own Rottweilers
Dent actually confirms this analogy
later on Jude was just a man dog this
dog comparison is pretty on the cute
cold wet nose the Joker is simple but
dangerous
he has no loyalties he's impossible to
negotiate with and that unpredictability
is what makes him the most threatening
the Joker tells Harvey that he's not a
schemer but of course it's not true
there's a lot more going on in that head
then he lets off and in this ranting of
Harvey some have theorized the Joker may
have revealed his possible origin if
tomorrow I tell the press I'd like a
gangbanger will get shot or a truckload
of soldiers will be blowing up nobody
panics because it's all part of the plan
his reference to a truckload of soldiers
led to a fan theory that the Joker could
have been a former soldier and Great
Society for forgetting about him
perhaps his facial scars could been
caused by shrapnel from an AED or
something and that just fits with his
general knowledge about explosives and
Firearms and how he was able to blend in
with the honor guard in a uniform and
handle a rifle
more recently comedian Patton Oswalt
speculated that the Joker could have
worked as a military interrogator based
on his earlier advice to Batman with the
head the victim gets all fuzzy now these
possible backstories are just fun to
consider but again the whole point is
for the Joker's backstory to remain a
mystery he's just more of a threat that
way by the way a lot of the Joker's
moves in this scene were inspired by the
graphic novel The Killing Joke by Alan
Moore which is one of the first darker
examinations of the Joker's psyche now
in The Killing Joke that Joker conducts
an elaborate social experiment to drive
a good lawman over the edge with one
really bad day and The Killing Joke it
was Commissioner Gordon here it's Harvey
Dent now one last detail in this scene
when the Joker arms Harvey with the
revolver and points the gun at his own
head look closely at his fingers The
Joker's thumb is holding back the
revolvers hammer so if Harvey ended up
trying to squeeze the trigger he
wouldn't be able to this is another
example the Joker's games he says he's
not a schemer but he is he wants Harvey
to feel like he has control that he
could have taken the Joker's life if he
wanted but really the Joker has some
bigger and grander ways to inspire panic
than that The Joker follows through on
his threat to blow up the hospital this
effect was practical Noland demolished a
real building this is actually an out of
use candy factory in the Chicago suburb
so they had to get this shot in one take
so when the charges didn't go off right
away and the Joker reacts like turning
around and checking the detonator this
was all improvised by Heath Ledger
I'm also contributed by Leger himself
was the second Joker video to Gotham
City News 4 which again Ledger worked
the camera for originally the script
called for this to be a video message
from the Joker's own mouth but Ledger
had the Joker give the words to Gotham
tonight host Mike angle by the way this
is actor Anthony Michael Hall who just
does not look like his eighties teen
star youth the script pages fly upward
as he reads them showing us that the
Joker who's actually hanging him upside
down by his feet meanwhile Batman shows
Fox his plan to burn the forest down
Fox's sonar technology expanded to this
big brother Ian's surveillance system
the design of this could have been
inspired by an art installation called
The Listening Post it was built in 2005
and now sits in the Science Museum in
London it screens display random lines
from the internet meant to display
online communication in a glance
Harvey goes on his afternoon killing
spree leading him to Maroni and if like
me you were wondering how the hell
Harvey ended up in the back seat of
maroney's car normally gave us one
amazingly subtle shot check this out
so as Maroni rounds the front of the car
on the far left of the frame you can
barely see Harvey sneak up behind this
guy knock him out in the back of the
head with the gun and drag him away it
happened so fast you barely see it now
Maroni definitely doesn't see the
scuffle because he happens to check his
watch at the precise moment then right
before Maroni gets to the back seat
check out that sideview mirror you could
see the reflection of Harvey Dent
sitting in the back seat on the driver's
side
there's no way Nolan expected viewers to
notice this to first go around he just
might get in there so that he could be
logically satisfied that Harvey Dent
could have possibly ended up in that car
Nolan you clever dog so let's move on to
the final game that the Joker promised
in his video earlier this involves two
fairies one containing average citizens
of Gotham the other containing convicts
that Gordon want to get out of there to
try to get them away from the Joker's
plan even though by doing so he ended up
putting them directly in the plan The
Joker gives each fairy the detonator to
an explosive on the other fairy telling
them both that if they don't blow up the
other boat by a certain amount of time
they'll blow both boats and of course
the boats are unable to communicate with
each other and hash this out now this
game is another example of the Joker
employing game theory it might actually
be the most famous thought experiment
it's called the prisoner's dilemma and
this one too prisoners are kept
for it from each other by prosecutors
trying to get them to testify against
the other prisoner if both prisoners
betray each other they both go to jail
for a long time if only one of them
betrays the other that one goes free but
the betrayed one is screwed and if both
prisoners stay silent to do nothing they
both serve time for a lesser charge
that's how they win that was actually an
amazing episode of the game show called
split or steal that illustrates this
idea wonderfully go watch it now in this
case the Joker is so convinced of his
cynicism toward human nature that he is
certain one of the fairies will go boom
either the criminals being evil and
blowing up everyday citizens or the
citizens cold-heartedly often the
criminals the Joker warn Batman about
this ultimate plan and his general
worldview earlier during the
interrogation you see their morals their
code it's a bad joke I'll show you when
they chips her down these are civilized
people they'll eat each other now it
would make sense for the Joker to assume
the worst about people the behavior of
the people of Gotham have proven him
right at every turn they always panic by
trusting the guy like Batman these are
people who celebrate vigilante justice
outside of the rule of law so if either
one of these fairies go boom it proves
the Joker right human nature is screwed
this conflict sets up the 3rd act of the
Dark Knight to be a battle for Gotham
soul that I mentioned before this
separates the Dark Knight from other
superhero movies which typically aim to
save the world from literal destruction
but by making this finale more than a
battle to save humans but a battle to
preserve humanity and human decency it
makes us all care so much more to see
the Joker citizens bail the desire to
have hope for yourself is such a
stronger impulse in an audience The
Joker presides over all this from a
nearby building where doctors are held
hostage though Batman's didn't realize
is that the innocent victims are dressed
like clowns whereas the criminals are
dressed as doctors this is what true is
parallel to the reversal of stereotypes
down on the fairies the more moral of
the two groups the ones more willing to
save lives are actually the ones dressed
in criminal attire the clown's are on
the average citizen boat they're the
ones who appear more willing to play The
Joker's game but at the end of the day
they do not the people of Gotham call
the Joker's bluff and while neither the
Batman nor the Joker destroy each other
the city of Gotham ends up being the
true hero
Batman's goal was always to inspire the
best out of people and he appears to
have finally done
that maybe accidentally the last we see
of Ledger's Joker he's suspended upside
down though the camera rotates to make
him appear right-side up this reflects
the Joker's final turning the tables on
his adversary he has one last trick of
his sleeve to turn Gotham on its head
his corruption of Harvey Dent and being
upside down with the Joker's anarchy and
these final moments leaves us in a state
of unease that he might be right which
is really the best place to leave us
with the Joker
the final scene returns us to 250 52nd
Street the palindrome make an address
where Rachel Dawes died it also returns
us to the three-headed conflict at the
heart of the attempt to save Gotham City
this battle of the soul of Gotham has
transferred from hundreds of people in a
staple portion down to Gotham's why
Knight himself one man does Harvey Dent
being lost being that all of Gotham is
lost well Harvey's final coin toss for
Gotham's feet lands on the good side up
so in a way that's a good sign actually
by the way it could be a nod to two
faces in in Batman Forever
when Tommy Lee Jones is the asymmetry
Sam impression died with the coin he
flipped for Batman's fate landing on
heads after saving Gordon's son and naki
and Harvey to face off the ledge Gordon
thanks Batman thank you this doesn't
call back to the final lines of Batman
Begins I never said thank you Batman
decides to save Harvey Dent's reputation
repeating Harvey's you either die here o
line from earlier after his selfish
romantic heroics cost him both Rachel's
life and Harvey's reputation
Batman has learned what it means to be a
true hero to make a self-sacrifice even
if that means turning herself into a
pariah to carry the sins of society
Batman has learned that he cannot do
this alone it takes all of society to
stand up and have faith in their own
decency
faith rewarded it's interesting that
Batman says these words over the image
of Lucius Fox destroying that invasive
surveillance system now Fox's ethical
objections reflected the political
debate in the mid-2000s over the Patriot
Act which expanded the surveillance
power of the US government agencies
after 9/11 the conclusion that Batman
and this movie want us to draw is that
technology and weapons and restricting
freedoms may be ways to fight terrorism
but really everyday people rejecting
terror
even when under threat is the only way
to fully vanquish it and in case this
happens too fast or pales voices to
raspy no one provides Gordon son as an
audience surrogate to explain this all
to us like we're five because you said
hero Gotham deserves but not the one it
needs right now Gordon is saying that
Gotham City deserves a selfless
scapegoat willing to carry their sins
because they're a bunch of jerks who
won't carry it themselves but that right
now Gotham needs an untarnished
courageous public servant whom they can
look up to as a murderer and that hero
that Gotham needs right now is Harvey
Dent the white knight the memory that
the public has of him before he became
this dark two-face but the hero Gotham
deserves the hero who can assume all
their guilt without being corrupted the
hero we never have to thank the hero
who's willing to accept our hatred is
the Dark Knight okay now that we've
reexamined this movie in detail a couple
questions I want to leave you guys with
did in the Dark Knight use two-face
enough as a villain Christopher Nolan
has said in interviews after the fact
that if he knew he's gonna make a third
movie he probably would have kept
two-face alive also another question
which superhero movie do you think has
come closest to top in the Dark Knight
comment down below with your thoughts
and I obviously love talking about this
movie so I'm really eager to open up
this conversation with you guys you can
also tweet me directly at yeh vas and
follow new rockstars on Twitter for
updates on our videos like this video
share it around subscribe to the
rockstars and check out my breakdown of
Batman Begins I go know a lot of good
stuff with that movie and of course keep
an eye out for the final Nolan Batman
film breakdown of the Dark Knight Rises
thanks for watching everyone